apple scans your phone for illegal
content master faces are able to bypass
almost any facial recognition software
and wally is real welcome to ml news
it's monday
all right before we get into things this
video is sponsored by weights and biases
weights and biases is of course the
one-stop shop for any machine learning
researcher or practitioners weights and
biases can track your experiments with a
single line of code it lets you
reproduce and analyze your experiments
it lets you understand your data it's
with you all the way from conception
idea research development up until
deployment today i want to talk to you
about a feature called sweeps now a
sweep in weights and devices is a hyper
parameter optimization search if you
will the cool thing is you define your
experiment you define the range of
parameters you want to search over and
then the system does the rest for you
you can even run this in a distributed
fashion you can have lots of agents at
lots of different places they're all
going to pull the code from the central
server pull the new hyper parameters try
them out and then report back in the
background there is a bayesian
optimization algorithm going on deciding
what parameters to try next to optimize
your objective they even have early
stopping so you don't waste resources on
runs that are clearly going nowhere and
have i mentioned you can run this in a
distributed fashion so here's one of my
sweeps as you can see you get your
output as you're used to from weights
and biases in a neat dashboard you get
an overview over all your runs but in
addition you're able to see the progress
of the sweep you're able to see which
ones succeeded and which ones didn't it
will analyze directly how important each
one of the parameters is individually so
here it tells me that the learning rate
is the most important parameter and it
has a positive correlation with my
objective function one of the coolest
views is this one here that tells me
which of the combinations of hyper
parameter ended up at a certain place so
i can filter for runs with particularly
low validation loss and then i can see
what are the learning rates what are the
epochs like in this particular runs now
there's obviously much more you can do
in terms of analyzing sweeps you can run
this much larger you can look at
individual samples of your best runs
pretty much everything you're used to
from weights and biases so if until now
you've tuned your hyper parameters
manually try this out let it do the work
for you go to bed and in the morning
come back to find the system has found
the best possible hyper parameters for
your problem not only is it easier but
you'll understand more about your
problem once you see it in this light of
course this is only one of the features
of weights and biases they have many
many more including ways to analyze your
data ways to export your models ways to
keep track of everything that you're
doing and ways to send reports around to
other people or generally work in teams
personal accounts are free with
unlimited experiments for you if you're
an enterprise that'll cost a bit of
money but hey you're an enterprise and
there are three options for academic
teams there are even options to
self-host if you need to be compliant
with any sort of regulation so give it a
try go over to weights and biases that's
1db i think at least that's how you
pronounce it 1db.ai
and have fun ciao
[Music]
all right our first story today is not a
particularly fun story techcrunch writes
apple confirms it will begin scanning
icloud photos for child abuse images
this has caused quite a bit of stir in
the community especially since apple had
all these adverts in the previous years
about what happens on your phone stays
on your phone was very privacy related
end-to-end encryption friendly and all
of these kinds of stuff and now all of a
sudden it seems like they're gonna scan
all your data for things they don't like
of course it's not a case in favor of
child abuse images or any kind of
illegal content people are worried about
privacy more generally so i think it's
important to say what exactly is gonna
happen here or at least from what we
know apple will scan your photos that
you are about to upload to icloud as i
understand it icloud itself is encrypted
so apple technically has no way to scan
the icloud photos because they are
encrypted with your key that rests on
your devices however they can scan
content that's on your phone now i'm
gonna guess there might be a legal
reason for it in that
they might sort of kind of be
responsible for that content once it
goes to their online service however
that's not something i know but of
course once the technical methodology is
in place to scan the photos that are
about to be uploaded to icloud from your
device you can use the same technology
to essentially get access to any data of
any user there's no technical limitation
after all why only these photos should
be scanned and just because apple
promises that it won't do it doesn't
mean they won't do it in the future or
they can't do it and that already tells
you a little bit why some people say it
is a problem because of course there is
also no technical limitation that says
that it can only scan for child abuse
images or any sort of illegal content
and for that it's a little bit important
to dig into what the system actually
does so the way this works is there's no
classifier essentially in there to
classify child abuse images from
non-child abuse images there is a
database so the police essentially
collects databases of these materials
which means that those are individual
photographs or movies that are sent
around by certain people that are
illegal and the police keeps track
exactly of the files that go around so
this is the first important thing they
only want to detect if you on your phone
have one of the files that they already
have in their database classified as
illegal content and the way they do it
is by comparing hashes now traditionally
a hash would only match if the file is
exactly the same bit for a bit so what
you do is your phone would download the
database of hashes would hash all the
photos on your device that are about to
be uploaded to icloud
wink and then it would compare those
hashes to the database of bad hashes and
if one matches it would upload it to the
police alternatively it could just hash
all the contents upload that to the
police and then the police could do the
comparison in any way if these are
actually true hashes
they're unlikely to reveal what data you
have on your phone and that's likely the
argument that apple's gonna make right
here in that just because you upload the
hashes of what's on your phone you can't
necessarily reconstruct the images from
that so your personal photos are safe
even more so if your phone downloads all
of these hashes and then compares them
locally and only sends if in fact there
is a match however there are multiple
problems with this first of all you
don't know what's going in this database
technically some political party could
simply enter things into that database
that they know are likely the opposition
or some rebel group is likely to share
around amongst themselves they could
even instigate such material and then
they could just wait and see what phones
blip up so you confiscate one phone from
your political opponent you run all
these hashes and you put them in the
database and all the phones of the
associates of that person would then be
automatically reported by this system so
the potential for abuse here of the
people who control what's in the
database is enormous second as i
understand it the hashes that are used
right here aren't like classic
cryptographic hashes they are what apple
calls neural hash but what is in effect
a locality sensitive hashing algorithm
so here's an article by tyler neylon
about locality sensitive hashing which
explains the concept fairly well and it
makes sense to use a locality sensitive
hash in this case because what you want
to detect is if two images are the same
meaning display the same thing for
example if i take an image and then run
some sort of jpeg compression on it it
still shows me the same thing however
the bits have all changed so a classic
hash would not be able to recognize that
image anymore however a content aware
hash would or should at least be able to
recognize that this is the same image
youtube has been doing this for a long
time with their content id system
detecting when someone re-uploads a
video by someone else even if that video
has been re-encoded so as far as i
understand it what apple does is they
train some kind of neural network that
gives them a representation of what is
in an image and then they run that
through a locality sensitive hashing
procedure locality sensitive hashing is
essentially a system that allows you to
find neighbors in very high dimensional
space very efficiently so the neural
network would produce a space of images
and place each image somewhere with the
intention that images containing similar
or the same thing would fall very close
to each other and you can do that with
neural network the question is you don't
want to run an inner product search over
this whole space all the time like that
would fry your phone probably so what
locality sensitive hashing does
essentially it divides up the space into
buckets so here it's straight buckets
and then these kinds of buckets once you
combine all these buckets you get sub
buckets so you get sort of a division of
space and for each point you can check
is it to the left or to the right of a
particular line and if two points match
in being to the left or to the right or
up or down respectively for any
particular line that means they're in
the same bucket and probably very close
together at that point then you can
actually go ahead and check if they are
actually close together or not this is a
good way to find approximately nearest
neighbors in high dimensions so real lsh
algorithms are a bit more sophisticated
but that's the essential concept they
work by so is this going to help well i
would say yes in first instance but then
i think very very quickly you'll realize
that adversarial attacks for example can
be crafted against these kinds of system
given that the system computes the hash
on your phone that means you have access
to the model on your phone and having
access to a model is a very very very
good target for crafting adversarial
attacks technically there could now be
an entire market of systems that perturb
images on your phone automatically such
that they just scramble the lsh because
most of these hashes aren't going to be
in the database so if i just assign my
image some random hash meaning i run an
adversarial attack such that it is just
going to be somewhere in this space most
likely i won't hit any of the hashes in
the database and therefore
all my photos are not going to cause any
hash collisions and therefore i
completely evade that system now the
question is of course uh how easy is
this going to be especially given that
it is supposed to circumvent detection
of illegal content there's going to be a
bit of resistance but there's definitely
quite easy ways it seems to circumvent
this system and we have to ask ourselves
are we really ready to give up uh basic
privacy are we really ready to let the
companies build in these giant back
doors that have massive potential for
abuse for
what is essentially a method that can be
pretty easily evaded when it's used for
what it's really supposed to be used for
i don't have the answers but um i would
err on the side of user privacy so
that's my take on it tell me what you
think in the comments all right a quick
afterthought here we now also have the
technical summary of apple there's a lot
of content in here notably it goes into
a lot of detail on how exactly the
technology works what neural hash is
supposed to do for example you can see
that the left and middle image have the
same neural hash whereas the right image
does not have the same neural hash so
the neural hash is supposed to be robust
to certain transformations that you
might do with the image while still
preserving its content therefore as i
said you couldn't just compress the
image or change its color saturation a
little bit and evade the neural hash
apparently though after the neural hash
is computed there is also this blinding
step which means that it essentially
goes through a classic hash function and
therefore the adversarial attacks on the
system become a little bit more
difficult now since this is all still on
device it's absolutely possible to evade
the neural hash using an adversarial
attack what is less possible is to frame
someone meaning that you send someone an
image that is specifically crafted to
hit the neural hash filters as illegal
content but it's actually just kind of a
normal image that you have adversarially
crafted now with an untargeted
adversarial attack you can evade the
filter but if you want to trip the
filter you really need a targeted
adversarial attack and because of this
blinding step you don't know what to
target so the only way to actually craft
such an adversarial image to frame
someone is if you yourself already have
an illegal image that you can target
with the adversarial attack so there's a
lot more in this technical report right
here and i invite you to read it if you
are
interested and i might actually do a
full video on this if this is
interesting enough to people it's not
necessarily machine learning it's more
cryptography and systems design but
still is pretty cool
[Music]
all right while we're on privacy the eu
parliament approves mass surveillance of
private communications from the european
pirate party writing today the european
parliament approved the e-privacy
derogation allowing providers of email
and messaging services to automatically
search all personal messages of each
citizen for presumed suspect content and
report suspected cases to the police the
european pirates delegation in the
greens efa group strongly condemns this
automated mass surveillance which
effectively means the end privacy in
digital correspondence so this sounds
kind of the same but it is slightly
different while apple announced that it
will do something this is simply the eu
saying that you can do something however
what you can do now seems to be a pretty
big breach of privacy now of course just
because companies now are allowed to do
something doesn't mean they will do it
but probably it means they will do it so
yeah but what are you gonna do use
signal well then just apple swoops in
and scans your messages before you send
them so i guess we'll just go back to
sending pigeons around
[Music]
all right on a bit on a lighter note i
stumbled across this book by rancho wong
that explains machine learning as
answering two basic questions so this
accompanies a machine learning class and
explains machine learning in the
essentially answering faqs this is a big
faq of that class and it's quite good uh
it's explained very concisely what do
embedding layers do embedding layers
convert a token an integer to a vector a
list of floating point numbers
that's fairly concise and then you say
when do you use embedding layers when
you want to process text text can be
converted to integers but because neural
networks are don't directly understand
integers there's a bit of a typo here i
guess could i change this i can make a
pull request
suggest edit
fork
check cool
i was pretty stupid and actually the
recording you're seeing is the second
recording in fact i forgot the first
time to record my screen and what
happened is is pretty funny in that so i
was i was presenting this book and i
actually saw a typo in the book and then
i immediately opened the pull request
and fixed the typo and the pull request
got approved and i was like yay ml news
and all and i thought that would make
for some pretty good content and i was
really happy with myself and it was
really neat and all and then i realized
i forgot to record the screen so now i'm
just going to show you a compilation of
me being absolutely
self-congratulatory for finding a typo
have fun good job ml news community we
did something give yourselves a pat on
the shoulders this is this is unplanned
by the way
uh yeah
ml news improving the world story by
story so as you can see it is not
entirely thorough
or particularly technically accurate or
anything like this if you're a beginner
if you're new into a particular subfield
of machine learning that's treated here
this might be a good place seems fairly
concise way to learn about the
fundamentals of given subfields
okay we have some new data sets coming
out two data sets by google both are for
nlp is especially for conversation one
is called time dial and it tests the
model's understanding of sort of the
sequence of things whether or not it
understands uh the flow of time
and especially if the participants in
the conversation talk about things that
happen one after another if the model
can correctly infer things about this so
here you can see uh what's the date
today today is september 28 2007. i have
a meeting this afternoon when will it
begin it'll begin at three o'clock
what's the time now and then the model
is asked to fill in this blank it is
something something and then continues i
have to go now i don't want to be late
the model says don't worry time is
enough what's the most likely filling in
the blank so you'd have to reason k
meeting is this afternoon it will begin
at three yet after that it says okay i
have to go now but time is enough so
maybe it's a bit before three you know
not like one to three or something like
this but it also not the day before or
so so out of the four options you have
here the first ones would be okay
because they fit the constraints uh the
last ones would not be okay and in fact
in this uh absolutely not cherry-picked
example i'm sure uh the t5 both t5 and
bird assign uh most mass to the last
examples the data set uh is essentially
made up of all kinds of these
conversations and giving you options to
fill in and you have to determine the
ones that fit the constraints most the
other data set is called this full qa
and
tests disfluent questions so it takes
the squad data set which is a question
answering data set and it rewrites it
into questions where the speaker just
kind of turns around mid question or
corrects themselves or or inserts
something or says like oh no that's not
what i meant i meant this other thing
and this can get quite complicated
because you can start with an entity and
then say oh no no no no but then still
refer to that entity when you rephrase
your question so the data set is
supposed to test the model's abilities
to handle that data sets like this in
general are pretty cool because they
test
sort of
human aspects of conversation however
state of the art on these data sets is
probably going to be reached by models
that just heavily over fit to whatever
the problems the data set construction
mechanism is so if you evaluate things
on these data sets what i think should
be done is you should just train like
your regular model without these things
in mind and then evaluate on them as
sort of one of the things maybe we can
add those two to to the super glue suite
or something like this which gives us a
more accurate picture than simply
releasing them and then and then have a
leaderboard for them that's just my
opinion
in other dataset news uh facebook
research releases vox populi which is a
speech data set so there's speech data
from the european parliament event
recordings some of them are even
annotated or translated interpreted into
other languages so this is a very big
data set unlabeled and labeled speech
data so if you work with speech this
might be something interesting for you
next news google tensor debuts on the
new pixel 6 this fall google tensor
apparently is some sort of hardware i
don't know this is a giant marketing
piece it just says the google tensor
chip will make everything very very fast
and machine learning and the new ui and
then on the essentially and it'll
actually say anything about the chip so
um your phone is going to be able to do
number numbery crunchy crunchy way
faster than it used to be able to do it
that's all i can say for now
the pentagon believes its precognitive
ai can predict events days in advance
machine learning could help the military
make proactive decisions rights and
gadget so this is an article and it
sounds a bit like out of a dystopian
movie but apparently the us military has
very large efforts into using ml to sort
of predict icky situations that are
about to happen and once you read into
it it's apparently not that different
from what they've done so far so far
they just had like a whole bunch of
people analyze all kinds of satellite
imagery or emails from people that they
just found on their computer like people
sent it to them their private emails
that's why they can read them legally um
and they just had all these people go
through all this data essentially
manually maybe with some assistance and
now ai is supposed to just be able to go
through this data a lot quicker and flag
any information that might be relevant
for the human reviewers the technology
itself seems fairly neutral and actually
pretty useful in certain situations
given that it's the military using it it
might have a bit of a bad rep but again
it demonstrates that most technology
doesn't really have a sort of moral
underpinning by itself it's uh mostly in
most cases about the deployment of any
type of technology like you could use
the same thing to predict days or
minutes or hours in advance when icu
patients will become unstable people
actually do it and the underlying core
technology is not gonna look very
different from what is done here
so researchers from mit and cmu release
sketch your own again which
is a paper and the method in the paper
is essentially you take a gan that you
have trained on some sort of data set
here for example on a cat data set and
you're able to additionally input a
sketch as you can see right here and the
system will adapt the game such that the
outputs sort of match that sketch of
course there's quite a number of hyper
parameters in here a lot of engineering
decisions but in essence it's a pretty
pretty cool way to control the output of
gans and this is quite a hard thing to
do and it's not entirely clear how to do
it a lot of people research sort of
disentanglement of features in gans so
you can control individual dimensions
directly but that kind of requires you
to have either a data set of these
individual dimensions so you can
actually really take them apart or you
just end up with some dimensions and you
have to figure out what they are in
order to control seems like a pretty
cool thing you can give the gan a sample
and in this case not even a sample of
real data you can actually give the gan
sort of a steering direction directly of
what you want it to output so i can see
this has many more applications beyond
images and sketches technically you
could apply this to a lot more stuff
where you need to control the output of
a generative model by some sort of
demonstration which doesn't even
necessarily have to be in the same space
as the things you're trying to produce
so overall very cool check it out
[Music]
next paper that caught my attention can
a fruit fly learn word embeddings by a
whole consortium of researchers of
different labs working together on this
paper now
it's click bait let me explain the paper
itself is actually pretty cool so we
understand fruit fly brains fairly well
they're approximately like this now when
i read the title of this paper is i want
to see a fruit fly learn word embeddings
or at least an attempt at doing these
kinds of things however it turns out
that the paper constructs a sort of
abstract model of the fruit fly brain
and then shows that that abstract model
can in fact learn word embeddings much
like the word embedding methods that we
know from nlp again the the research
itself is completely valid and very cool
i i was just sort of caught out by how
important uh a title of a paper is
because had it been for a different
title a technical title i probably would
not have clicked on it so the lesson is
if you're trying to get people to read
your paper a good title can go a long
way
[Music]
okay the last paper that caught my eye
is generating master faces for
dictionary attacks with a
network-assisted latent space evolution
this by the blavatnik school of computer
science in tel aviv and by the school of
electrical engineering in tel aviv this
paper essentially uses evolutionary
algorithms and i love the darwin in this
picture just to make clear we mean
darwinian evolution and not lamarckian
evolution hashtag nola mark so this
paper constructs what they call master
faces and apparently just these faces
just 10 faces so each of these rows are
these master faces just these faces
combined are able to match a vast number
of facial detection algorithms so what
that means is if i go out and i
encounter a facial recognition system to
like let me into a door or into a phone
or anything like this i can just try out
these 10 faces and there is a high
likelihood something like 40 to 50 that
one of them will actually work which is
insane this shows sort of the
brittleness of the identification part
of these facial recognition algorithms
the potential for abuse for this is is
large like someone could get access to
all the photos that you're about to
upload to icloud or something like this
like imagine that that'd be terrible fix
this
all right we just have one helpful
library this week high torch releases
the python profiler version 1.9
so this seems to be a rather major
upgrade
that includes distributed training view
memory view gpu utilization view cloud
storage support and jump to source code
which replaces the old feature of walk
to source code well in any case if you
use pytorch and you ask yourself why
your code is so slow maybe try giving
the pytorch profiler a look
next news zeroad is getting
reinforcement learning capabilities this
is a strategy game that is kind of
popular with some people the cool thing
is that it has now a direct interface
for reinforcement learning meaning that
it exposes an api essentially compatible
with the
gym interface that you know from basic
rl so they even go through setting up
some sort of a
task for you with these five spearmen
fighting against these five cavalry and
they take you through training a dqn
agent and then evaluating it directly in
their game so if you're interested in
reinforcement learning as it pertains to
controlling games maybe this is a good
topic for you to dive in
and the last news yahoo news riot
beachbot rover uses artificial
intelligence to clean up cigarette butts
so apparently there once was an engineer
whose son dug up a cigarette butt at the
beach and the engineer looked around and
saw all kinds of cigarette butts lying
around realized that they're quite bad
for the environment and also not very
pleasant to step into so he teamed up
with his friend and built this thing
called beachbot or bibi for short so
this is essentially an incarnation of
wall-e it goes around and automatically
picks up cigarette butts at the beach
how cute is that how neat so it does
that fully automatically i think the the
bigger goal here is to sort of develop
ai and robotics applications for
sustainability the project in itself is
not going to save the world here they
write it can scoop up about 10 cigarette
butts with its grippers within 30
minutes and it has to recharge about
once every hour so pretty much it's out
competed hopelessly by a single
chainsmoker but what can i say it's very
very cool but i think such a robot could
be better used to actually go and just
poke people who smoke at the beach in
the first place so bibi will get a
companion pokey bb and pokey best
friends on the beach let's go stab some
smokers and then pick up a cigarette
butt
all right that was already it for this
week's ml news on this beautiful
beautiful monday i hope you learned
something today if you did subscribe if
you did not watch the video again then
subscribe please check out weights and
biases and i wish you a very pleasant
week i'll see you around bye
[Music]
[Applause]